Okay,
let me start in.
This lecture is about national security
and it's about the conflict that's
evolved during the 20th century between
national security and environmental
quality and human health.
Uh,
so I want to explore that because so
much money in the world is spent on
national security and
it has the potential to,
to,
uh,
invade individual rights to
diminish personal freedom,
uh,
to diminish privacy.
Uh,
at the same time,
it has a potential to concentrate
power and authority among elites,
political elites,
a wealthy elites,
a technical leads,
uh,
and so that it's threatening
to a democratic participation
and policymaking in a
variety of ways.
Uh,
and as we move through the course,
you'll find that secrecy
is not just an issue,
that we need to figure out how to manage
better in the public sector relative to
classified information.
And this is the topic of today's session,
but it's also a critical
issue in the private sector.
Uh,
the growing use of confidential
business information.
Uh,
the Goo goo growing obscurity of product
ingredients as a globalized markets
cause products and services
to across national borders,
uh,
without any clear identity about
a components or potential effects.
So national security and
environmental quality.
I want you to think about this case
and other cases that we deal with as a,
a problem of managing intelligence.
I'm not meaning to imply that
other people are not intelligence.
I'm thinking about
intelligent and a meaning to,
uh,
hopefully get you to think about the idea
of a legal system that would produce a
public that was literate and capable
of understanding the quality of the
environment around them.
Uh,
what's threatening and what's not,
so that potentially they could,
they could manage their exposure to a,
to chemicals,
they could manage,
uh,
the effect of human behavior on,
on a,
uh,
a variety of environmental issues
such as endangered species.
So the,
the,
the purpose for the title of my book
that I'm having you read you poor things,
uh,
is,
the idea of thinking about
the origin of knowledge.
You know,
where do we get the information,
where do we get the data?
Where do we get the knowledge?
Who produces it?
Uh,
and what we'll see today is
that a knowledge about the
environmental effects of
national security or produced
predominantly by the Defense Department,
uh,
they control sites are they
control the technology,
uh,
in weaponry and weapons delivery systems,
making it extremely difficult for the
public to understand really what the
dangers might be.
Where does the knowledge flow?
Is it intelligible,
uh,
is it understood the distinction between,
is it intelligible and is it understood,
is really critical?
It involves a literacy,
it,
uh,
involves educational background,
technical competence and who owns it?
This is really a key question for law.
Uh,
you can think about this in terms of
it being an intellectual property,
right?
Question.
Should the public own it?
Uh,
should the public be able to keep,
should the government be able to
keep the knowledge from the public?
Uh,
should the private sector be allowed
to own it and should they be allowed to
keep knowledge from the public?
So think about it as a problem of
understanding production and flow of
knowledge.
Uh,
because environmental quality is
always going to be elusive until we,
we,
uh,
create a public that really
is a far more intelligent,
so to speak,
uh,
understanding,
than it currently is.
So what are the purposes of secrecy?
And I'm kind of fascinated by,
uh,
the growing a classification of
information in the public sector so that,
uh,
in in US history,
never before has the government been
classifying more information than it is
today.
You know,
at the same time,
there's a very interesting,
uh,
cultural,
change that we're witnessing
in your generation,
uh,
related to Facebook.
I mean,
I've never seen a generation be so
interested in revealing secrets or
information about themselves as your
generation is so disconnected and in a way
between government policy
and what's going on that,
uh,
in,
in social circles among
younger generations.
How do terror and warfare
depended upon secrecy
when to secrecy threaten
national security?
One,
is secrecy necessary
for national security?
Uh,
and how is it related
to individual rights?
These are key questions that I hope you'll
keep in mind as we move through this
lecture today.
They're common scripts
in environmental history,
no matter whether or not you consider
this case or the case of an endangered
species.
A case of,
of uh,
uh,
managing water quality,
managing a sustainable agriculture
who knew about the problem,
who knew about contaminants in this case?
When did they know,
when do they inform the public and
what do they do about the problem?
These are critical questions and secrecy
is a central component of all of them.
So that the history that I want to go
through today is really one that is very
brief.
It only spans the period
between 1944 and 1963.
So in this period,
uh,
the atomic weapons,
the first atomic weapons
were designed and tested.
The first one at Los Alamos,
New Mexico in 1945 followed by two,
uh,
uses of atomic weapons.
The only two aggressive uses in,
in a world history or one on Hiroshima
and the other on Nagasaki killing
hundreds of thousands of people and
resulting in injuries and death and
heritable Muterric stations,
uh,
that,
have,
has affected generations of Japanese.
Uh,
so this compressed period
is really quite striking.
Now why in the world would we
be talking about this issue?
Uh,
which seems so old now.
It's part of the Cold War,
uh,
in,
in a class on a current
environmental law and policy.
Well,
I'll tell you a bit of a story.
In,
uh,
2003 I was in the [inaudible]
real book library and if,
I don't know if you have
visited the Beinecke Library,
uh,
but,
it really is a remarkable place.
It's got a wonderful rich
store of information,
especially on the American West.
Uh,
but I found out just by surfing the
net that they also have all of Rachel
Carson's original research material.
Now,
Rachel Carson wrote silent spring,
uh,
and the sea around us and a number of
other books and his rather famous in that,
uh,
environmental history,
particularly for her work trying to get
the public to wake up about the dangers
of pesticides,
especially related to wildlife because
she was a wildlife biologist working for
the fish and wildlife service.
Well,
it turns out that all of her
original research materials,
including about 120 boxes of material,
are stored in the,
in the basement of a key library.
So going through those,
as I was trying to understand
the history of pesticides,
uh,
I found one file that was
on nuclear weapons testing.
Uh,
and that file was incredibly dense.
and as she,
as she had conducted a research,
by the way,
it's very different than what we do today,
uh,
which when our research
is almost all electronic,
uh,
she would hand copy material.
There were no copy machines,
uh,
that she,
she had access to at that point in time.
Uh,
and then she would write notes,
little side notes,
interpreting it as you went along.
So going through this,
I realized that,
that all of her work on pesticides where
she wondered what happened to them once
they were released,
uh,
where they went,
how did they make their way into the soil?
Why we'll wildlife,
uh,
the canaries in the,
in the mind,
in a sense.
Uh,
what were the wildlife telling us
about human hazards in human risk?
Uh,
and,
and what was wrong with
current law and policy,
uh,
that would allow that kind of release
and a non accountability on the part of,
of the private sector.
So she learned that way of thinking,
uh,
that,
that narrative logic,
uh,
she learned that,
not by studying pesticides,
by looking at the history of the Atomic
Energy Commission in the 1950s and how
they came to understand a radionuclides
and what happened to them and the kind
of threat they posed to water quality,
to air quality,
how they got into wildlife,
how they got into human tissue.
So this is a story of today.
So the idea that a,
the success in any of these
cases is dependent upon
very high quality science is
a very important idea.
And remember what I said the other day,
that,
uh,
perhaps 95% of the science,
in the field of environmental science
is conducted in the private sector,
never sees the light of day.
Well,
in this case,
this is the,
the best example of state
science at an enormous scale.
The Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
had an unlimited budget.
They had unlimited authority,
uh,
and they had a unlimited capacity
to tell a story about a danger and,
and,
uh,
the,
the importance of pursuing a atomic
weapons development in order to protect
national security.
So this time span just gives you
the number of tests per year,
uh,
between 1945 or actually
the number of explosions,
1945.
And then 1960 to 1963,
president Kennedy,
uh,
worked too with the Soviets to,
to pass the limited test ban treaty.
And since that time,
uh,
an atmospheric testing
has been severely limited,
no nuclear test worldwide
between 45 and in [inaudible] 96,
uh,
roughly about 2000,
maybe about 2,400.
After 1963,
the majority of tests or the
number of tests actually went up,
uh,
but most of them went underground.
So underground testing has allowed,
and we'll see later on in the,
and the lecture,
uh,
that,
there have been certain
parts of the world that,
uh,
it's,
it's been agreed,
uh,
among nations that had
this nuclear capacity,
uh,
to avoid testing.
So outerspace is now off limits.
Uh,
testing in the South Pacific is now
off limits because it was the site of,
of of many highly intense tests,
uh,
of,
hydrogen bonds.
And also a testing in the,
on the Poles is,
is a restricted by
international agreement.
So this is a very limited period of time
and many people don't understand where
these tests were conducted.
Some of the South Atlantic Salmon,
Mississippi,
uh,
some in Japan,
New Mexico,
the Pacific Ocean,
uh,
the Nevada test site,
Johnson island,
Christmas Island,
a new attack in Bikini,
which are part of the Marshall
Islands in the Pacific.
I'll be speaking more about this
and show you some film clips,
uh,
on,
next Tuesday when we reconvene.
One interesting aspect of this
history was the behavior of clouds.
Fuchs,
uh,
who was a theoretical scientist working
at Los Alamos on the development of the
first weapon,
the first atomic bomb during what
is known as the Manhattan project.
And he had access to top secret material,
uh,
a very,
very highly skilled,
uh,
a physicist and he passed most of what
he knew onto the Soviets in the late
1940s.
So he was tried and convicted of
espionage and Britain in the 1950s and he
served nine years out
of a 14 year sentence.
This is fascinating to me and think
about the nature of the sanction here so
that the Soviets gained
their understanding of,
of how the U S,
uh,
produced nuclear weapons and
gained an understanding of,
of what our strategy was,
uh,
how we were testing it,
how were we were monitoring the effects,
what the intensity of the radiation was.
And the man,
uh,
serves only nine years in prison
lesson is kind of curious.
Uh,
most secrets have very short lives
and the more valuable they are,
uh,
the more limited is her life.
So I think about the idea of creating
a secret as creating a property,
right?
And so it creates a property,
Uh,
and it's value is,
is a dependent on many aspects,
uh,
of its,
of its character.
And A,
we'll explore that as we move through
the power of explosions on the Bikini
atoll in the South Pacific is something
to take note of a next Tuesday.
We'll come back to this story,
uh,
where the bikini islanders
were removed from their island,
uh,
through negotiation and
the use of eminent domain.
And then the u s,
uh,
proceeded to a test about 25,
26 different nuclear weapons,
including the,
uh,
the Bravo test in 1954 a that I'll show
you a clip of a in which was one of the
largest bombs ever exploded
by the u s in the atmosphere.
Okay.
The Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
created what they called Project Gabriel,
evolved to be called project sunshine.
Uh,
that lasted between 1949 and 1961.
So project,
sunset sunshine,
I became famous and it was the,
a collection of scientists
and the government,
uh,
working with the atomic energy commission
based predominantly at the University
of Chicago and Columbia University,
the Lamont laboratories.
So scientists were given,
uh,
you know,
virtually unlimited funds to conduct
research that would help the atomic energy
commission.
Understand the power of
their different weapons.
And there's some 200 different types of,
of nuclear weapons eventually that were,
were designed,
uh,
and,
some,
uh,
so large that they had to
redesign aircraft in order to,
to handle the weight and others so small
that they could be tactically carried
in a suitcase,
uh,
and,
be used under a field conditions
that were very difficult.
A different delivery mechanisms,
a delivery by aircraft delivery,
by missile,
a delivery by a artillery,
a delivery by suitcase.
So that,
uh,
you know,
a variety of different types of
bombs have different strengths.
And,
uh,
we're,
we're designed for different,
uh,
types of warfare.
So the sunshine scientist really
ramped up in the early 1950s.
And what's interesting is the way that
they thought about environmental science,
uh,
they wondered what happened
to the radionuclides no,
where do they go when a bomb explodes?
What happens?
Well,
you know,
dust particles get blown
up into the atmosphere.
Uh,
if you drop a bomb and shallow water,
it will take,
uh,
the material on the bottom of the water.
It will take the fish.
Then it will basically blow everything
up and the coral up into the end of the
atmosphere.
Uh,
it will also,
uh,
kill any birds that,
are in close proximity.
So test has a story about a bird's
raining from the sky on fire.
Uh,
it will also cause a pattern of movement
in the atmosphere that depends very
much upon climate and wind conditions.
Uh,
and the power of the bomb determines
how high up into the atmosphere of the
particles get.
So dozens and dozens of different new
clients or created a that some of which
had never been recognized before.
So trying to figure this out,
one of the first things they did was they
set up a monitoring system that makes
sense if you want to figure
out where something is going.
He set up a monitoring system.
In this case it was rather simplistic,
uh,
around,
the Nevada test site north of Las Vegas,
about 65 miles.
And people used to cluster on top.
So the casinos and the hotels
in the evening to watch the,
uh,
the bombs explode or get up really
early in the morning to watch the bombs
explode,
a highly visible,
given the,
the clear climate.
So they set up their monitors and they,
they presume that a,
or they'd captured the dispersal of Rec,
uh,
radiation.
Uh,
and then they began to get reports.
Our reports came in from
different parts of the country.
Uh,
some in North Dakota from people
that were mining for uranium,
uh,
that,
had carried Geiger counters.
And a one minor,
uh,
was,
was telling a story where he was eating
dinner at his campfire with his guy or
counter that he forgot to turn off
and the Geiger counter stopped,
started to spit,
split out,
and he,
Shit,
ah,
boy,
you know,
I've got to have this thing serviced.
It's,
it must be out of tune.
It must be a detecting
something that a is not there.
So he took it in to have it
serviced and found out that it was,
it was actually,
uh,
in,
in great tune and didn't need to be
recalibrated and went back to his site and
it happened again.
So he realized that,
uh,
gradually that something was
going on in the atmosphere.
It wasn't measuring anything in the
mine or a in nearby rock because it,
it normally in that place would be a,
would be silent.
He was picking up radionuclides that
were raining down in North Dakota.
A Polaroid became important in the
process of understanding the distribution
Polaroid film company,
uh,
because it's film was found to be exposed
when it arrived at doctor's offices
and hospitals in different
parts of the world.
And at that point in time,
they used to to,
uh,
put,
the Polaroid film,
uh,
the,
you know,
eight and a half by 11 sheets into boxes
and then they would pack the boxes,
you know,
not with the Styrofoam kernels that
we use today that will never go away.
Uh,
but instead they used to
pack it with corn husks.
So gradually they,
uh,
figured it out because they
could see in some cases,
uh,
the image of the Corn Husk,
on top of the,
the,
uh,
the film matching directly.
So what was happening?
Well,
the radionuclides,
we're intersecting a cloud.
They were raining down in this case,
in the Midwestern part
of the United States,
uh,
where the box had been and the corn husks,
we're exposing the film because
they had absorbed the radionuclides.
So they realized gradually that their
donut 200 miles in diameter around Las
Vegas was a completely inappropriate
to capture the scale of this problem.
This is a very important lesson in
environmental science and environmental
policy policy.
It's like,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
the analogy of the drunk leaning on a,
a light post looking for his,
uh,
his car keys.
Uh,
why is he looking under the light post?
That's because that's
where the light is a,
so that there are many,
many different stories about the
failure of environmental science,
uh,
and the ineffectiveness of environmental
law that flow from this problem of
misunderstanding the need for a
very sensitive sampling design.
In this case,
the stokes test in 1957 put
radionuclides into the atmosphere,
but they started moving in different
directions at different altitudes.
Ooh,
there's an interesting idea that's novel.
Uh,
no one thought about that before.
So here are the dashed line at the
bottom is moving at 30,000 feet,
whereas it just nix the
southeast side of Idaho.
Uh,
whereas the dust at 10,000 feet
shoots all the way up to Montana,
then it arcs up over southern Canada,
comes back over the Great Lakes,
and you see that arc of the dashed
line coming and breakdown across lake
Champlain and the New York,
Vermont border,
the Massachusetts New York border,
and then the Connecticut border.
Well,
that's pretty interesting.
Uh,
another test that they followed
created dust clouds that,
uh,
again,
we're driven by weather patterns.
And you see in this case
that a at 30,000 feet,
one swirled around Texas for about a week,
another one swooped all the way at 20,000
feet down into Florida and probably
would have been detected in if they had
rainstorms in Florida at the time of the
dust dust cloud that got there,
that would have been detectable.
And in the orange,
orange is an orange juice
and a in orange oils,
uh,
so that,
crops were being threatened and exposed
and in a variety of different ways that
a,
we're being driven by weather patterns
and we all know that even today it's hard
to predict what the weather's going to
be a within 36 hours in many parts of the
country.
So that,
uh,
the,
the state of weather forecasting back
at this time was quite primitive.
Uh,
so that basically told
these scientists and,
and again,
I can just imagine what they were doing
sitting across the table looking at each
other.
How are we gonna manage this?
What's going to happen if
the public understands this?
How are we going to maintain
our political support for the,
the weapons testing program so that we
can keep on building these weapons to
contain the Soviet sorta to strike fear
into their hearts following their policy
of deterrence.
The bigger the bomb,
the less likely we are to be attacked
by a other nations that would understand
that an attack would be simply suicide.
Well,
here is a chart which is an
amalgamation of different,
uh,
bomb blasts in the
pathways that they took.
A and the darkest areas are areas that
received the highest doses of radiation.
And,
uh,
these new Clyde's have half
lives that vary between,
uh,
roughly,
three to four weeks up to a 40,
50,
a hundred years.
Uh,
so that if you went to the,
to the center of the country in,
in Iowa and you took a test of the soil,
you could still detect many of these
radionuclides in the soil and they are
transferable from soil to crops and,
and up to,
uh,
to fruits.
So that,
uh,
this patchiness and fallout was
eventually recognized by the Atomic Energy
Commission in the mid 1950s and gradually,
you know,
once this information was
declassified in the early 1990s.
And the only reason I'm telling you this
story is because most of this knowledge
was eventually declassified.
I couldn't be here,
which is kind of an interesting thought.
I couldn't be here right
now telling you the story.
Uh,
had the declassification process not,
not occurred under the
Clinton administration,
uh,
once they realized that that the atomic
energy commission that kept all this
information,
uh,
from the public when they really had
no national security logic to do so.
So here is a,
a,
uh,
a map of the United States constructed
by the National Cancer Institute,
uh,
in the late 1990s,
that tick the dose estimates that they
got from the soils because they could
calculate back,
calculate the concentrations from existing
concentrations and knowing the decay
rate of different new Clyde's.
And they develop this map of,
of expected doses.
And then,
uh,
the,
the cancer institutes
started asking questions,
uh,
because they understood the dose
response relationship for radiation.
And these new Clyde's
is really pretty clear.
This is not like a,
you know,
you have to drink,
uh,
10,000 cans of Diet soda
to absorb Enough Sacrum to,
uh,
to,
to elevate your cancer risk a little bit.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
this is a science that,
are,
uh,
evolved in the 1950s largely because of,
of the importance to the military,
uh,
that understood the dose
response relationship,
uh,
quite clearly.
So,
but understanding a dose response
relationship ship meaning,
let's see,
the best way to explain dose
response relationship if you,
if it's not familiar to you,
is to,
uh,
especially for college
students is to think about,
uh,
a six pack of beer.
So he six pack of Beer,
you have one beer and you know,
you might feel a little bit of it.
Uh,
you have two beers,
two beers within 15 minutes.
I know you'd never do that.
Uh,
you have three beers within 20 minutes.
you have six beers within a an hour.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the,
the effect that you feel
the effect on your body,
uh,
depends upon the dose and
the concentration that
you're actually a circulating
in your system.
So they understood this relationship,
uh,
with great clarity with respect to
these radionuclides so that the cancer
estimates really are quite robust.
One interesting thing is that if you look
at the pattern of testing that really
it peaked in the late 1950s,
uh,
so that,
you see,
uh,
this is radionuclides in rainwater and
then there was an agreement not to test
for a period of two years.
And you see that the rain
water levels decline.
It's in the rainwater.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
It's in the rainwater.
What does that mean for a fish?
What does it mean for rivers?
What does it mean for,
uh,
parts of the West that a experience,
high levels of snowpack?
Well,
it means that a snowpack,
uh,
for example,
Jackson,
Wyoming,
a couple of years ago,
a Jackson Hole,
Wyoming received more than
600 inches of snow in,
in one year.
And in a matter of a about a month,
uh,
in,
in the period between
April and a late May,
uh,
you get basically warmer
weather melting all the snow.
So in this period of time,
you get this rush,
you get this pulse of radioactive
water that moves into a stream.
And Lo and behold,
where could you test that?
Well,
you could test that in
the supermarket where,
and in what supermarket
and Salmon Supermarkets,
Trod supermarket buying
Trenton sooner supermarket,
you could find,
uh,
these levels increasing in the,
in the Columbia River,
uh,
that goes by the Hanford
uranium enrichment plant,
plutonium enrichment plant in
Washington and the state of Washington.
So the water levels concentrations
were going up because the rainwater
concentration,
we're going up and the fish
concentrations were going up.
Uh,
and also people that were drinking water
out of wells that were fed underground
by the aquifer from the Hanford area,
they were also being exposed.
The per capita dose
was calculated as well.
And you see the,
uh,
the dip between 1960 January of 1960,
and,
uh,
late 1962 during the,
agreed,
uh,
cessation of testing.
So this information was,
was really quite,
quite robust.
So project sunshine,
uh,
basically pieced together this idea
that these new Clyde's were in global
circulation.
Uh,
they were contaminating every
aspect of our environment,
uh,
and they were making their way
into humans and particularly,
uh,
they were concerned about strontium 90.
Because,
uh,
if you have a diet that is low in calcium,
your body's going to absorb more
strontium 90 into your bone.
Uh,
also,
if you have,
uh,
a diet that's low in iodine,
your thyroid is going
to absorb more iodine,
uh,
one 31 than it normally would.
So understanding this,
uh,
this relationship between,
calcium and strontium 90 is very important
because it eventually led to calcium
enrichment of breads a of milk.
Uh,
so the four fortification
program was really,
uh,
it really had its origination and
recommendations by the Atomic Energy
Commission.
So the public thought,
oh,
we're just getting more minerals in our,
in our diet.
Well,
that must be a good thing.
The nutritionist must be arguing
that this makes a lot of sense.
Uh,
but in reality,
what was going on was that the Atomic
Energy Commission was a anxiously wringing
his hands,
recognizing that they've got to
figure out how to lower the dose being
experienced in the population.
The population had no
idea what was going on.
So project sunshine scientists,
they eventually attained 15,000 bodies,
dead bodies,
trying to understand the
distribution of these,
uh,
new Clyde's throughout the world.
Uh,
bodies from New York,
San Francisco,
Houston,
uh,
Japan,
India,
South Africa.
Why from other nations?
Well,
predominantly because they were
worried about the other nations,
uh,
coming back and,
and,
uh,
telling the United States that we
were contaminating not only their food
supplies,
which was going to harm their,
their ability to trade
products internationally,
uh,
processed foods,
water,
uh,
just about any kind of of,
crop you could think
of as well as animals.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
gradually over the period
between 1955 in 1960,
the atomic energy commission,
uh,
grew to really understand the
global distributional pattern.
Uh,
and how,
how people in certain areas of,
of Latin America,
in tropical areas,
we're really experiencing
quite high levels of fallout.
Why would that be a tropical rain forest?
They experience intense rainfall,
uh,
so that,
the rain was so high that it would,
it would concentrate the,
the new Clyde's in,
in,
uh,
some of the tropical forest areas.
So permission to take the body
parts was never sought or obtained.
A family members were,
were never consulted.
Uh,
bones were cleaned and
packaged and formalin,
uh,
and then they were crushed and analyzed
by laboratory technicians at Columbia
and other prestige has us institutions,
academic institutions,
uh,
and sometimes the bones
were pooled together.
Uh,
gradually they decided that they were
going to look for geographic variability
and there are going to look for age
related variability because they were
finding that a kids,
for some reason we're absorbing
more of the radionuclides,
especially strontium than the adults were.
So why would that be?
Cause it's something about their diet.
Was there something
about their physiology?
Well,
it had to do with their,
their rate of growth of bone.
So kids are,
kids are,
are growing most rapidly at
what point in their lives?
Well,
uh,
from time of conception
roughly till the time of 13,
but different organ systems and
different functions in the body,
a mature at different rates.
So statute statute for example,
is quite linear,
although you get this
really serious growth curve,
um,
uh,
in,
in Utero,
and then it goes up gradually,
gradually,
and then a more steeply,
uh,
during the early teenage years.
So you could figure out the,
that were correlated with these periods
of rapid growth and development.
So,
you know,
gradually,
uh,
these secrets started to leak out.
Uh,
and the US began to study fallout data
and once the Soviets had developed their
own capacity to make them
10 test a nuclear weapons,
the atomic energy commission
had this great argument.
Well,
there are new collides in our
food supply and in our bodies,
it's not our fault while we
take some responsibility,
but it's the Soviets fault.
And Soviets were actually testing
these weapons up in Siberia.
Uh,
and so the Siberian radionuclides work
tended to come down across Alaska and
across Canada and into the,
the,
uh,
western and Midwestern
part of the u s so in,
in,
in threads that are similar to the ones
that I showed you from the Nevada test
site.
So the,
the U S was,
was trying to at this point,
desperately maintain public
support for continued testing.
Uh,
in part because they were wondering,
well,
you know,
what would happen if we did have a,
a,
a nuclear war,
you know,
what,
where would the new Clyde's go and what
would our capacity to respond to me?
So these were legitimate
national security concerns,
uh,
that they were exploring.
So,
uh,
the u s began to release
some of its information at
the same time that a state's
started their own testing programs.
So you know,
just like,
um,
uh,
you find variability and air pollution
today from a motor vehicles depending
upon climate and,
and,
uh,
we're,
our vehicle uses most intense,
uh,
you find,
in this case a states being worried about
a specific patterns of concentration
in the crops that they grow.
Vermont cheese,
for example,
a or a mid western grains,
uh,
or a cattle grazed in,
in the western us.
So Minnesota,
Vermont and other states felt like they
were environmental hotspots and they,
that they're,
uh,
corporations were being hindered,
their capacity to trade,
uh,
nationally and internationally
was being diminished.
The U s finally started a,
an open test,
a of milk for radioactivity in 1957,
12 years after the explosions began,
uh,
and Linus Pauling who won the Nobel prize
for his work on nutrition,
particularly related to vitamin C,
uh,
came out with,
with his conclusion that the body really
discriminates against strontium and
favors calcium uptake if the
calcium levels were high enough.
Uh,
that prompted the,
uh,
the addition of a,
of a calcium is how I was saying to
milk bread and animal feeds as well as
fertilizers.
So this is quite,
quite curious.
Surgeon General,
uh,
for the u s denied that the
fallout hazards were serious in,
in the New York Times in 1959.
And,
uh,
so there was,
there was really quite an open public
debate in late in the late fifties,
in part that surrounded Eisenhower's
campaign to become president again in,
in,
uh,
1956.
And his competitor was his vice
president Adelai Stephenson.
So Stephenson,
uh,
basically broke the news that,
the atomic energy commission had been
hiding this information from the public.
And,
uh,
in the,
in this last minute a campaign effort,
uh,
he,
he claimed that there were genetic
hazards to future generation,
a risk of bone cancer and,
uh,
the inability to conduct
medical investigations.
Now this is interesting.
Uh,
so that,
that,
uh,
there's exposure that is universal.
Everybody's exposed
because everybody eats.
Uh,
and that means that,
that you really don't have any opportunity
for scientific control group that has
unexposed to figure out what the
long term health effects might be.
13 yell scientists including
Arthur Gauston of the
biology department who passed
away just a,
uh,
a few years ago assigned a statement,
a endorsing the views of Stevenson.
Stevenson lost Eisenhower
became president again.
And,
uh,
what was interesting
about it is that that,
uh,
transcripts from his,
his,
uh,
conferences is a national security,
team,
uh,
had been released in
the late 1990s as well.
And Co and Eisenhower,
uh,
eventually got to the point where
he was telling his staff that,
uh,
the levels are radionuclides
in the milk supply.
The buildup and especially in,
in,
uh,
children's bones was unacceptable and
something was going to have to happen.
And that prompted him to be
more aggressive in trying to,
to,
uh,
negotiate with the Soviets,
to,
uh,
to create some sort of a treaty that
would reduce atmospheric testing.
So I'm going to jump ahead here
so I don't run out of time.
The atomic energy commission also
was found to have withheld data,
recognizing that there were these
spikes in the New York City,
uh,
milk supplies,
data that was collected just prior to
the election that they understood posed a
problem.
They held that until
weeks after the election.
So it's kind of curious that
milk became the standard for,
for trying to figure out,
uh,
where the chemicals when,
especially powdered buttermilk
because it's dehydrated form,
uh,
it was easy to,
to send around the country.
And this chart I think is also
interesting because remember that the,
the,
uh,
limited test ban treaty of 1963,
really stopped protesting cold.
And what you see is a gradual decline,
uh,
in worldwide,
a fallout a represented by strontium 90,
and CCM one's 37 and milk.
So you see this gradual decline because
of the residency time in the atmosphere
so that these chemicals,
uh,
don't,
don't all wash out like quickly,
uh,
after the explosions,
they go into global circulation.
And there was great
debate at the time about,
uh,
the,
the amount of time that they
stayed in the atmosphere.
And the atomic energy
commission was arguing,
don't worry about it.
They're going to stay in the
atmosphere for a long period of time.
Why would they use that logic while they,
one of the radiation to dissipate?
So that by the time the new Clyde's got
down to the ground that they wouldn't
pose such an intense radiation threat.
Now that's kind of an interesting story.
So environmentalist's and,
and,
uh,
public health advocates were arguing,
no,
you don't understand this
pattern of deposition.
Uh,
it's often,
it's often more quickly
that it reaches the ground,
uh,
in a,
in a higher concentrate
and that higher intensity,
uh,
of radiation.
So that,
uh,
this story played out over the
1970s and 1980s until gradually,
uh,
you find,
1995,
it really leveling off
to what it is today.
Curiously,
you see the spike and CCM,
one 37 in 1987,
1986,
1987.
Anybody have any idea what that might be?
Chernobyl.
Chernobyl released more CCM one 37 to
the atmosphere after the explosion that,
where the dome with a building,
uh,
blew off.
And,
uh,
there was a fire that was
uncontainable for a period of weeks,
spewed more radiation into the
atmosphere in the form of cesium one 37.
Then many of the earlier
atmospheric weapons tests did.
So,
um,
I began by telling you that,
uh,
under conditions of secrecy,
the people that hold
power over the secret,
uh,
have great narrative advantage.
They not only control the,
the,
the search for the data,
they control it's interpretation and
they control the story that's told to the
general public.
And a couple of elements of the story
are kind of fun to think about because
we'll see these,
these,
uh,
same narratives evolve for pesticides,
for plastics,
uh,
for a variety of different
environmental problems.
Is the problem human induced,
uh,
or is it,
more important to worry
about natural sources,
natural sources of radiation?
Hm.
So you see these comparisons between
the dose that you would get by having a,
a glass of milk or a having the diet
of a trial comparison between that and
number of flights that you would
take across the United States.
And you probably know that you get
a measurable dose of Radiation,
uh,
when,
when you,
you're up an aircraft.
So this comparison
between a human induced,
uh,
exposure compared to natural exposure.
Another,
a good example of that would be radon.
And in Connecticut we have
a problem with radon gas,
which is radioactive being admitted,
especially from the kind
of rock that we have here.
And particularly along the coastline.
A heading east down
here along long island,
long island sound.
Uh,
and my basement,
my house for example,
we had a radon problem.
We're radon gas was a,
not just measurable,
it was,
it was really quite high.
So we had to figure out
how to remediate that.
You dig a hole in your basement floor,
you put a little fan and a pipe
in and you'd get rid of it.
If you don't do that,
uh,
then you're,
you're,
you risk exposing your family to,
to rate on a,
which is a very well known carcinogen.
The estimates of desk from radon exposure
in the United States are actually
quite high.
You know,
a 40 to 50,000 people
per year are believed to,
uh,
get lung cancer as a,
as a result of radon exposure.
So that the comparison of natural
sources of radiation to human induced,
uh,
sources related to national
security protection,
uh,
there's some legitimacy to that and
you have to be very careful about it.
Also,
the idea of relative risk,
well,
why are we worrying
about radiation when we,
we should be worrying
about other kinds of risks.
And we'll see that with
respect to pesticides,
where,
uh,
you find,
say the,
the car manufacturers,
uh,
concerned about,
the emission technology requirements
under the clean air act for,
for,
uh,
tailpipe emissions,
and they,
they point other sources,
other critical sources of,
of a human exposure to air pollutants
such as power plants or incinerators.
So this idea of risk comparison,
uh,
really,
was,
was well honed in the 1940s and 1950s
by the atomic energy commission.
And then,
excuse me,
in that case,
uh,
the concern was to express
the risk relative to,
uh,
misunderstanding,
the,
uh,
implications of,
of nuclear war,
uh,
and,
not being able to protect the public,
uh,
from excessive,
patterns of exposure that
played out by the way,
in a variety of pretty unusual ways.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
many people in the 1950s built a
fallout shelters in their backyard.
My neighbors did it.
My family never had the,
the,
the means to do it,
but my neighbors had these,
these concrete buildings
that they built underground.
They look a lot like basements and
they would store water and food and,
and,
uh,
they would practice their drills where
they would run down into the basement.
And,
uh,
this was especially important during the
Cuban missile crisis where we came the
closest that we ever have to,
to a nuclear war.
So the idea of how long do you
have to stay in the shelter,
uh,
to protect yourself?
Well,
you wouldn't know that unless you had
done these atmospheric tests and you
understood how the concentrations
diminished over a certain period of time.
So the idea of relative
risk also deserves merit.
This is also an interesting time when,
uh,
the,
the first environmentalist,
uh,
had formed their organizations
back in the 1940s and 1950,
say tended to be medical doctors.
Uh,
the very first environmentalist and the,
one of the interest groups that you
recognize today is consumers union that
produces consumer reports,
magazine compares a product quality,
uh,
and uh,
often,
uh,
environmental or health
claims and products.
So consumer's union was very
active in collecting milk,
uh,
in this case from 48
cities around the world.
No one talked about human milk.
And I found this to be quite fascinating.
So for the entire decade,
uh,
no one spoke about,
oh,
well,
you know,
if it's getting into cow's milk,
why isn't it getting into human
milk is getting into human milk.
What's the capacity to be transferring
these radionuclides across generations
via breastfeeding?
Well,
in part,
I think it was a,
uh,
a shyness,
a reluctance to,
to talk about breastfeeding in public,
which was common at the time,
but it was clearly an issue that the
atomic energy commission had recognized.
And I found a document,
it was a document that a was
declassified that was produced in 1952,
uh,
that,
that demonstrated quite clearly that the
atomic energy commission had made the
connection like that it's in cow's milk,
it's going to be in human milk.
Uh,
we know that,
uh,
these,
these compounds are capable of causing
mutations in genes and some of those
mutations are inheritable.
They can be transferred across generations
in addition to the fact that we're
exposing,
uh,
the next generation via via breastmilk
in addition to infant formula and milk
and other,
other parts of a,
of a small child or an infant food supply.
Also,
uh,
the,
the group saying became
famous at this point in time,
uh,
a group that was politically
active to protect pregnant women.
And this history is the first history,
uh,
in the 20th century where children's
health became a logic for more,
uh,
for a,
a stronger set of regulations
and rules relative to a meeting,
something that,
uh,
could be thought of as dangerous to the,
to the atmosphere.
Uh,
so,
uh,
gradually,
by the end of the decade,
the Atomic Energy Commission recognize
that does strontium 90 accumulated in
soils,
it accumulated in foods
it accumulated in kids,
they knew how to calculate with a cancer
risk was because they understood the
dose response relationship.
So they were basically sitting on a gold
mine of knowledge that they had kept
from the public,
uh,
as best they could during
this period of time.
So here's a list of 60 years of
experimentation with nuclear weapons.
43 years,
45 years of negotiation.
And you see the Antarctic Treaty,
the agreement not to conduct
the testing and the Arctic.
This is common heritage
for all of mankind,
so to speak.
You see,
the hotline agreement,
uh,
before,
a nuclear war,
uh,
was,
initiated.
There was an agreement,
uh,
to call up a,
the Soviets and,
uh,
try a last minute to attempt it.
Negotiation,
the limited test ban treaty
that I just described,
the outer space treaty,
uh,
the,
seabed treaty,
it's not legal to,
to,
uh,
conduct experiments in the seabed.
Uh,
uh,
so that,
common property around the world is,
is now protected by international treaty.
Uh,
however the United States is testing,
uh,
at a rate that,
is never been less,
uh,
the testing,
however,
the majority of it is underground.
And I'll show you a
clip next next week of,
uh,
some underground tests,
that,
uh,
created earthquakes in
different parts of the world,
uh,
particularly in Alaska.
And we also see a very curious effect
where these former testing sites,
uh,
were eventually translated into
fish and wildlife reserves.
So that's another interesting thing to
try to explain and I'm going to close
today with one more thought for you.
This entire story unfolded
between 1945 in 1963.
Uh,
the environmental protection
agency was created in 1970
in the safe drinking water act was
created in 1976 so there was absolutely no
protection.
There was no monitoring of public water
supplies through this entire period of
time.
Uh,
the clean air act was not in existence,
so that there was no,
there was no protection against,
uh,
the radionuclides as air
pollutants are air contaminants.
And finally,
in 1976,
the environmental protection agency set
an acceptable radioactivity limit for
drinking water of one millisievert or
that can be translated into 0.1 rim per
year.
How about reading that nuclides and food?
Uh,
one would think that this history,
uh,
would provide a very good logic for
establishing limits for radionuclides and
food.
Uh,
but you know,
as the Chernobyl event in 1986,
uh,
unfolded,
we realized that we were not alone
and not having any sort of limits for
radionuclides and food.
Uh,
neither did any of the
European Union nations.
So trade was completely disrupted.
Uh,
tens of billions of dollars of food
was lost following the Chernobyl event
because Italy had one standard for,
for acceptable a contamination,
whereas Germany had another,
uh,
they're all the nations
had different standards.
But just keep this in mind that the
United States still has no maximum permit,
maximum permissible limits.
The takeaway point here,
simply when secrecies combined with
the absence of environmental and health
surveillance [inaudible] the public
opinion and politics favor the development
of hazardous technologies.
In this case,
uh,
this knowledge was controlled
by elites and then relate,
released selectively
to an unknowing public,
uh,
in an attempt to,
to encourage them to a favor
continued atomic weapons testing.